[Music]
this is michael thompson
he was born this morning
his heritage is good
strong healthy stock no hurry of
abnormality
[Music]
what kind of person will you be michael
thompson has made its impress on you
what town you'll grow up in
this is the street where you'll spend
most of your early years
this is the house where you will live
your first school
and the people
who are the important people in your
world michael thompson
there's old mrs ratus who lives next
door
[Music]
she doesn't like children very much
then there is homer buchanan who lives
nearby
[Music]
homer likes children
and there's mr perry the milkman
[Music]
and andy the grocer's clerk
the postman who comes every day
and the policeman who directs traffic at
the school every afternoon
[Music]
and the whole succession of school
teachers
and children in and out of school
[Music]
in a few more years a baby brother
[Music]
and most important of all
your father and mother
this is your world michael thompson and
the important people in it
the people who will love you who will
push you and pull you help you and
hinder you in your job of growing to be
a man
[Music]
let's look at your world a little closer
michael and see what it will do to you
let's start with your father daniel
thompson and your mother elizabeth
channing thompson
they love you very much michael
they want you very much
[Music]
but he's so red there's nothing wrong
with him is it no he's a fine boy
i think he's beautiful
yes they want you very much michael and
they have definite ideas of what they
want you to be
preconceived ideas
dreams that will influence the way they
act
michael
michael f thompson you're going far son
your father expects big things from you
he wants you to be better than he is to
grasp the opportunities he missed to
realize his unfulfilled aspirations
and your mother expects things too
she wants you to love her as much as she
loves you to need her love to need her
care now and a little later and forever
dreams michael all parents have dreams
everyone has dreams most of the time
they don't even know they have them
[Music]
in a few days they take you home
and some of the most important days of
your life begin
[Music]
you need a nice warm world michael you
need loving care and gentle affection
you need a happy secure home
and your parents give you everything you
need michael gladly and easily
uncritically because now you are exactly
what they want what their dreams want
[Music]
everyone knows what a little baby is
like
charming helpless and appealing
your father and mother know it too
michael
they don't expect you to be anything
else
and then you start to grow up michael
and there's a wonderful excitement about
every new thing
well about almost every new thing
there are some new things that don't
quite fit with your mother's dream
you're growing up now and you don't like
to be cuddled all the time
he lets me hold him anymore
michael take that dirty thing out of
your mouth
let him alone he's growing up
and very often michael the things you do
the things every baby does
don't always fit in with your father's
dream either
does he have to be so messy about it
here let me feed him
eat
eat
let him alone daniel he's just a baby
first father says let him alone he's
growing up and then mother says let him
alone he's just a baby why don't they
let you alone
each of them has a dream about what he
wants you to be
each tries to mold you according to his
dream
mother can't let you be independent
father can't wait until you're ready to
do new things
remember mother's dream
she wants you to cling to her forever
remember father's dream he wants you to
grow into the ideal he has set for you
michael you're growing up the way you
have to grow up
doing what you have to do
exploring new things going back to old
things even when it's not quite the way
your father expects it to happen
even when it's not the way your mother
would like it to be
well michael you keep on growing
and as the years pass there are other
times happy times too many of them when
what you really are comes very close to
what your parents think you should be
you've learned to feed yourself pretty
well by now
a little closer to your father's dream
of you
[Music]
and when it's time for bed and your
mother tucks you in
you come a little closer to her dream
[Music]
sleep is good michael when you feel
secure with your parents when you know
they love you
[Music]
but sometimes when you wake up and the
night is dark and quiet
you get a little uneasy
for little children there's something
strange about the night
something unfriendly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
even your toys don't comfort you and you
need comforting michael you want your
father and mother
nothing very special or urgent about it
but
what will happen michael will your
father get angry and say
get back into bed right this minute
is that what's going to happen michael
or will your mother get her worried look
and say
my baby
come to mind
is that what will happen will they make
more of this moment than is really there
[Music]
or does this happen what ought to happen
[Music]
you see they can modify their dreams
your father and mother
they can sometimes break away from their
fixed ideas of what you ought to do and
be
it seems so easy for them to spend a few
moments making the night scene warm and
friendly again so that you don't mind
going back to your room
but it isn't easy when mother wants to
keep you a baby and father's impatient
when you act like a baby
as a matter of fact michael you're a
little of both
sometimes a baby and sometimes quite
grown up
no it isn't easy
this business of growing up
it isn't easy in the outside world
either
[Music]
you stay away from my flowers michael
thompson go on scoot
scoot
there is no place in her dreams for
children
mrs ratus thinks little boys are horrid
monsters who want to trample her flowers
[Music]
but homer knows they're not monsters
homer can accept boys and girls pretty
much as they are and he likes them that
way
children don't get in the way of homer's
dreams
[Music]
oh fine bring them down come on we'll
put them on
[Music]
all right fella come on out here
let's put the gloves on come on give me
a white one
[Music]
that's it
children love homer because he always
lets them try out new things without
forgetting that they're still children
now come on hit me hit me
wonderful man that homer
[Music]
that's right michael take it home that
wonderful experience take it home and
share it
your father's pleased he understands
about these things but your mother is
upset because
well she doesn't want you to learn
things like boxing boxing gods
where did you get those from son
oklahoma gave him to when he shot me at
the bottom and i knocked them down
we did eh well let's put these on and
let a real expert show you how to use
them
why does your father have that edge in
his voice
is he hurt because he wasn't the first
to show you
the first thing to do is to get your
position right
why does he have to make this a lesson
lead with your left
and cross with your right
go on cross with your right
now the main thing is to keep moving all
the time keep jabbing keep coming in
keep your guard up
you're wide open now jab with your right
your chin gotta learn to defend yourself
watch it now
no it isn't easy to grow up michael
especially when your father expects so
much of you when he's got a dream he
wants very much to come true
and it doesn't quite come true for your
dreams either michael and in a few weeks
now michael mommy's going to the same
hospital where she had you you remember
the building with the white pillars
and she's going to have a little baby
for you to play with that's right mike
then you'll have a brother to play ball
with don't say that daniel it might be a
girl nonsense it'll be a boy and we'll
name him robert you're so sure of
yourself why ever since i played with
dolls i've wanted a girl baby dolls
don't be silly elizabeth wait till you
see him mike you can teach him to ride
your bike and box with him and all you
think about is boxing boxing
remember the white pillars remember the
white pillars remember the white pillar
remember the white pillars remember the
white miller play with god play with god
play with dogs don't be silly don't be
silly don't be silly don't be silly
don't be silly box with him bucks with
him box with him box with him box with
him box with him
boxing boxing boxing boxing why do you
keep hopping on that
you're just confusing the boy saying
things like that of course mike you'll
have to share your toys with him but you
won't mind that because you've got lots
of toys i don't know why you do it
daniel i really don't i don't want them
brother for children the difference
between dreams and reality is very
slight so slight that when the baby
brother actually comes michael isn't
very sure
be careful michael he's very delicate
mustn't touch the baby son is that my
brother mommy yes michael
but he's so little
[Laughter]
what'd you expect someone as big as you
[Music]
what did you expect michael someone as
big and frightening as your daydream
[Music]
he cries when you touch him
michael let that baby alone
[Music]
he's so little
but he can get you in trouble
you think he'll always get you in
trouble
you think he must be your enemy
will your frightening dream always make
him your enemy
even when you are both a little bigger
[Music]
will he still be your enemy a few years
later
now you stay here i'm gonna go play ball
you better take me with your auto mommy
don't you dare
[Music]
that's the way it can be michael when
you have a preconceived idea about
something about someone
that's the way it is with everyone
without our even knowing it we try to
make things happen the way we expect
them to happen
that's the way it is with your parents
too with your mother trying to make you
into her dream
with your father trying to make you like
his dream
they really don't want the same boy and
you can't make either dream come true
it never happens that way
let's see what it might be like michael
if your mother's dream were the chief
influence in your life
your mother who protects you too much
who worries too much
who can't bear to let you grow up to
grow away from her
after a while you even feel guilty about
growing up
oh my
to think that my boy is big enough for a
suit like that
you don't think it's too old looking for
him
gee whiz mom you gotta let me grow up
sometime
yes michael she's got to let you grow up
but she'll do it grudgingly unwillingly
it's the new things like your first long
pants that make her feel lonely and old
she doesn't want to lose you
every new thing every first time is a
threat an attack aimed at her dream
how does it feel going to your first
dance son oh all right i guess
taking it girl
not exactly
no
he's not taking a girl
why do you feel so troubled michael is
it because you know that you're not
really what your mother wants you to be
her baby boy
oh you'll go out with girls before very
long
[Music]
but you won't be happy about it
[Music]
you'll get married too but no matter
whom you marry there won't be much joy
in it
[Music]
women make you feel guilty
all women just the way your mother makes
you feel guilty
yes michael that's the way it would be
with your mother's dream running things
but suppose instead of your mother's
dream dominating things happen things
always happen the way your father's
dream forces them to happen
remember that night you woke up a little
frightened
get back into bed
get back into bed right this minute and
that day mrs ratus chased you
stop sucking your thumb remember when
your new brother arrived michael let
that baby alone you ought to have better
sense than that you see michael it isn't
that your father doesn't love you
it's just that he expects too much
goodbye mom goodbye pop
michael come back here
but pop we want to go swimming come here
when i call you
what do you mean slamming that door that
way haven't you got any better manners
than that
but
i was late
don't answer back that way
have you cleaned up your room
be quiet now go upstairs and clean up
that mess
it isn't easy with a father who won't
ever listen to you
who is never satisfied
i know he wants to go swimming but we've
got to teach him responsibility
responsibility yes he wants you to have
all the virtues michael he wants you to
be the strongest the finest the best of
all
[Applause]
it's a good feeling when you win michael
when you're on the winning side
your father should be pleased
pop
hey pop
we won eight to five and johnny got a
home run and a three bagger how many did
you get son
i got a two bagger and a couple of
singles
well
better luck next time never satisfied
always want you a little different a
little better more like his dream
but you don't know about his dream
michael and you're all dup sooner or
later you stop trying that's why you
avoid those school dances
you want to go but you're afraid you'll
come close but you won't go in
it's hard to do anything when your
father is always saying don't do this
don't do that be the best
why don't you look where you're going
he's wrong but he makes you feel the way
you do with your father afraid
a sharp tone of voice a disapproving
attitude a person in authority
any one of them can make you feel afraid
angry
resentful
after a while it won't even have to be
your father or anyone outside of
yourself
that makes you feel that way
[Music]
oh
oh i'm so sorry
hiya mike
well did you get the raise no i quit
quit
why what did he do
who
he didn't do anything
i didn't give him a chance i quit first
not very pretty is it michael either way
mama's boy or papa's boy
and they wouldn't like you to turn out
either way your father and mother even
though it would be their dreams that
helped to make it that way but let's go
back back to the hospital on that first
day when the nurse took you to your
parents
[Music]
it doesn't have to happen that way
michael either way because your parents
can break away from the rigid patterns
of their dreams or at least they can
learn to hold them back a little
your father and mother don't have to be
perfect to be good parents they can
learn that only by bringing up a child
you michael for your own sake and they
get the kind of grown-up son they want
with parents who help you mature
properly and fully you'll have a warm
secure baby world where you are
protected and loved and cared for
a world where you are free to follow the
gradual inevitable path to manhood at
your own pace
and with the sympathetic and
understanding help of your parents
michael you can succeed in overcoming
childhood fears
you can avoid having any preconceived
ideas that your brother is going to be
your enemy
it's difficult for a small boy to
understand what a new baby is going to
be
and it's natural for him to be a little
curious
of course he cries when you touch him
and you're distressed
but your father will explain things
your brother's a little young to play
with just now
we sort of have to take care of him for
a while you and i but you wait till he
gets loaded
with your parents loving guidance you
can learn to accept your brother
to accept him as a friend an equal
[Music]
with parents who can modify their own
dreams to fit your needs you can lead a
happy and productive life
well-equipped to make your way in the
world
[Music]
hi mike how you doing
well equipped to make your way in your
world he can't play he's too little he
is not too little he's my brother maybe
he is really too little but michael you
carry some weight in your childhood
community they accept your judgment
you're a person in your own right
michael grown and matured in an
atmosphere of love and mutual respect
an atmosphere that encourages you to go
forward joyously to manhood and maturity
[Music]
an atmosphere that prepares you to find
your place in the world with confidence
and the best use of your abilities
you can be a well-integrated man michael
a whole man
well qualified to take your place in the
family the community
the world
[Music]
you see
there are three michael thompsons
and probably even more
those other two
and this one
one of them will be you michael
the others
will of the wisps
might have been
so
you